I was scared to death because I don't
have to tell you I'm white and it was a
totally minority school and I didn't and
I knew they had in excess of 12 gangs
and I didn't think they would want me
there
and so but I went and the first day I
was there before school started and one
gang member threw another one through
the plate-glass window at the front of
the school and I went out and blood was
just shooting from his throat and it is
your very first day it was my first day
in the school hadn't even opened yet and
I I said I must be some kind of crazy
old woman to be out here thinking I can
make a difference in this school because
I didn't have a clue about how to deal
with gangs or at all you figured it out
though well I finally figured it out but
it was interesting they told me that
they didn't tell me that until I was
there that the former principal or gang
one gang had a contract out on her life
and and I began to think maybe they had
an alternative motive sending me out
there and then I learned that nobody
else wanted this school so I thought if
I'm going to do what Ashley wanted to do
which was truly make the world a better
place
then I've got to stick with it and I've
got to go with it and so I did so you've
turned the place around well we did we
want us now we did and the gangsters
helped me thanks turtle the gangsters
helped me a lot
what really happened was one day I came
in from a meeting and there was a riot
on the campus and in eminences we're
taking police officers away where they
had been trying to settle things down
and so when I went in I mean I was
bewildered I really didn't have a clue
what to do and my assistant principals
were going to send 32 gang members to
alternative schools to get them off
campus the problem is we had done that
over and over and over and nothing
changed so I said no we're not going to
do
so they came to me and said you know you
will probably be fired for this because
you're breaking the rules and I thought
then what a blessing it would be if they
fired me and so I said no we're going to
do this because in education we keep
doing really dumb things over and over
even if it's not working so and there
are another rule was you don't ever
bring rival gangs together to discuss
anything but I did and I and I brought
them in into my conference room and I
asked them what it would take to bring
peace into their lives and peace into
the school and at first they wouldn't
talk to me and they didn't they would
just look mean mug each other and then
they would mean mug me and I was
determined not to be scared by
mean-mugging and it's just looking mean
and looking like and I've got you and I
want to do something to you and so I
just kept sitting there and I were you
frightened inside it was frightened but
they didn't know it and I would just
smile and say let's talk about this and
my daughter was a psychotherapist she
would always say let's get in touch with
your feelings I hated it when she said
that to me so I didn't say that to him I
just said let's talk about this and see
what we can do